wiping the debt
i mean think about everything else
that's happened over the last year you
know they're putting
money economic stimulus packages putting
us further in debt
like the debt doesn't matter and
depositing money in people's bank
accounts
meanwhile we're walking around with our
faces covered and
i don't know but this shit's not normal
it's not okay they say it's a new normal
but
there's something very wrong with what's
going on right now yeah and i
and i think that it's more than what
people are being told i i can feel that
you know i i definitely do i think
probably a global financial reset not a
digital currency
if you look at last year id 2020 in the
country of bangladesh
so they they ran a new um it was like a
a
pilot program and where they were
digitizing identification
vaccination records your digital
identification i don't know the extent
of it all yet but the idea is to get all
of your
all of the information related to you in
a digital form
and i believe the state of washington um
bill gates home state
is that a coincidence so did a similar
program
so i think ultimately the goal is going
to be
get our identification digitized
get our currency digitized and money's
dirty right
it's been everywhere like there's like
trace elements of cocaine on every
twenty dollar bill yeah so
it's it's filthy it's full of germs back
here you'll get kova touching that
dollar so
don't touch it just use your credit card
right so make it a dollar on the screen
but here's the benefit to the
to the central banks the the bankers is
they control your spending power
if they want to turn you off all they
have to do is flip a switch
or press a button right now you can't
buy anything
you're valueless because your value is
just a
number on a screen so
you know there's a huge incentive for
the powers that be
not trump not biden who are the powers
that be
well so i mean this is conspiracy theory
but what the
what do they say the mayor of engine
blood there's like 13 bloodlines and you
can google it
that supposedly own the majority of the
world you know the ross childs the
rockefellers the vanderbilts
stuff like that so also people believe
that they're aliens or they're reptiles
so david ike kind of says that they're
all lizards you know they're like
hybrids or they're like reptiles i had a
guy on here the other day he was talking
about how
they're they're the ones who run the run
the country and they're
all aliens from another dimension they
do believe that i don't
my my conspiracy my conspiracy mind is
limited way before we get to the lizard
talk but
you know i i i read uh i did read the
perception deception in prison by david
aiken he has some
really crazy interesting far out beliefs
what is that what is the title the
perception deception the perception
deception it's like dude it's thicker
than the bible it's crazy
but it was an interesting read just to
see like how far out like this dude
david ike i don't know if you've ever
heard of him i know he is so he went to
peru
peru and had the spiritual awakening and
he was like connected with the infinite
i'm guessing he went and did something
like ayahuasca or something just
excluded that part
but he said he was like standing in the
middle of a field and just like
had this this spiritual awakening so now
every year he visits that place that he
goes to that same field and like
tries to reconnect with i don't know but
so
so like this the the conspiracy
community would call it the annunaki
they would say that like yeah and the
spiritual community or the religious
community would call it the nephilim
the fallen angels so you know
they do have archaeological proof of
like elongated skeletons
um they've actually found these
elongated skulls and you know there's
different theories on how those came
about but
in giants you know seven eight nine feet
tall
so christians would believe that it's
like the fallen angels
came here to to breed with our women
and like reproduce the the other
theory is that the anunnaki a a
reptilian
race came to earth to extract the
surface gold
and bred with the neanderthals and
created homo sapiens
hmm so people have some pretty far out
you know how to
how would i know i had no idea but
well there was just the news that came
out on npr just the other day
about that they released
evidence or it was something i didn't
read the whole article i read like the
top headline of it but they basically
uh they released information about
manipulating chimpanzee dna or mixing
monkey and human dna together embryos
they were like [ __ ] with embryos or
whatever
wow and it's like very very close to the
the whole stoned
or the not the stoned apron the theory
that aliens came down and injected their
dna
into primates lower primates to create
us right to advance evolution
i don't know what to believe but what i
do know there's a documentary called all
wars or bankers wars
and that's really eye-opening like when
you when you follow the money and you
realize that like there's a certain
class of people that get to create the
money
that we're spending they create it okay
out of thin air
yeah they create it we attribute the
value to it we say
yep we ex we accept this as our as our
medium of exchange is our method of
exchange we now give it this value this
dollar is now worth a dollar
because we say it is we believe it is
all value is subjective though so but
this certain class of people gets to
create that
and then they get to lend it out at
interest they get to create something
that didn't exist
they get to lend it to everyone in the
world
and charge interest on it and
they get these people in debt when
you're in debt to someone what are you
you're a slave you're a debt slave
you're a slave you're enslaved
they own us they own you so
you know in that much economically
i can't really dispute that fact so
all wars are bankers words what that
what that aims to illustrate in like 45
minutes
is that the bankers fund both sides of
every conflict
they profit regardless of who wins it
isn't about who wins
and if you look at like how wars have
how we're waging wars now like we didn't
wage a war on a specific enemy we waged
a war on terror
we waged a war on drugs
drugs is the enemy terrorism is the
enemy
but isn't war itself terrorism you're
dropping bombs on people yeah
that's terrorism dude like that that's
terrorism
so we're waging a war on war
i don't know i don't know man it doesn't
make any sense but when you think about
it
sure it does it stimulates the economy
yeah thousands of jobs billions of
dollars yeah
it's all about definitely all
financially driven everything everything
so you know i say those are the people
creating creating this construct that we
live within
and that we accept is normal and those
are the people that
see bitcoin as a threat or solid as a
threat and realize that
you know this is threatening everything
that
that we've created it's threatening our
power structure it's
decentralized autonomous organizations
threaten
our everything if people realize that
they can create
tech and not build a business behind it
and better the world like turn it loose
where we can't regulate it
and they can actually derive value
extract value out of that
without paying taxes without
legitimizing it through registering a
corporation or
or you know hiring and paying
all these fees and penalties and you
know everything that comes with starting
a business the barrier to entry to start
a business is not
easy if you don't know someone with
money or you don't really understand how
to do the work to
like for me it's working two jobs it's
burning the candle at three ends just to
make ends meet and make sure my
developers are paid
and i'm willing to make that sacrifice
because i understand that's what it's
going to take
i wasn't born with a silver spoon in my
mouth if i don't do that i won't make it
and some people have that drive some
people are willing to go the extra mile
and make that happen for themselves
and kudos to them that's great but
the thing is is it shouldn't be that
hard
if you really have the passion and and
drive and
and the right intentions and
the the idea like in an idea of
meritocracy like
if if the idea is good and execution is
good you should be
successful and i think that you know
government just further complicates
things
you know taxes and regulations and
licensing and it just i don't know man
it's it's not a free market we don't
have a free market this is not
capitalism
it's a hybrid we we have a socialism you
can call whatever you want but we've got
all these socialistic safety nets you've
got
you've got i know i'm stepping on some
toes here but like welfare and section 8
and
you know this is you're literally
redistributing wealth
you're taking wealth from one category
of people and you're saying well we
can't we are our brother's keeper we
can't let our brother
fall short we can't let our brother
starve so we you know we have to make
sure they're housed and clothed and fed
why i know that sounds horrible i'm not
saying me as a person if i have the
ability to help i want to help
but should i be forced to at gunpoint
because that's the reality what's we've
disassociated that reality
but that's the reality if i choose not
to pay taxes what will happen to me
armed of the teeth irs agents will kick
in my door just like the dea did
they will shove guns in my face and they
will throw me in a cage
we use violence to extort our own people
and that is not okay that is barbaric
it is not okay that is everything that
is wrong with the world yeah but if the
country is a community
you know if you have if you're if you
live in a community and you want to want
your community to thrive you have to
protect everybody
involved and if you and the idea
makes sense that if if we are a country
if we are a community together we have
to help everybody we don't want
to have a country full of losers well i
agree with that
so i i agree that we sh like if i have
the ability to help you
and you're and you're trying to do
something meaningful i should help you
but i can't agree with the absolute
everybody because i also believe that
not
everybody deserves to be helped some
people don't even want to help
themselves
and if they're making poor choices and
they're not willing to do the work
they're not willing to actually put
their best foot forward and pull their
at least their own weight
just contribute enough you can only take
from the table
what you're willing to bring to it if
you're not willing to bring anything and
you're just on the take take take take
you are not deserving right that is my
belief and i know some people
would say well even if that person wants
to just take and doesn't want to
contribute we should still make sure
he's fed
i can't go that far i don't believe that
because you're taking from me you're
stealing from me
and and i'm i'm working 16 hours a day
just so that i can get to where i want
to be in life why should i support you
[Laughter]
too